leute ich hab meinen kanal mittlerweile
seit fast drei jahren
seit dezember 2013 spiele ich meinen
kräften ungefähr auch genau so lange
spielt schon online minecraft pvp und
einige von euch spielen sicher auch
schon sehr sehr lange selbst minecraft
pvp und in dieser zeit habe ich mal so
trifft man auf besondere menschen und
denen ist das heutige video gewidmet
denn in dem heutigen video möchte ich
wie schon im titel steht euch die fünf
häufigsten minecraft spieler zeigen ich
habe ein bisschen gedanken gemacht hab
mir überlegt okay was sind die fünf
minecraft spieler die am meisten
abfangen die richtige abzocker sind und
diese fünf städte heute vor also haltet
euch fest wirklich nicht so sehr auf
denn ihr werdet die leute sehr
wahrscheinlich selbst erkennen und euch
an momente erinnert fühlen wo er schon
selbst gespielt habt und euch aufgeregt
habe über diese person deswegen legen
direkt los wird nummer eins der
schlechte spieler der beleidigte oder
möchte ich erst mal vorneweg sagen dass
es selbstverständlich nichts schlimmes
ist wenn man nicht gut in minecraft ist
es ist sogar vielleicht gut wenn wir uns
die leute anschauen die nachher noch im
video kommen ab weil die zwar gut sind
aber aus gründen die vielleicht auch
nicht ganz so cool sind aber auf jeden
fall gibt einige spieler die schlecht
sind in minecraft was wie gesagt nicht
schlimm ist aber selbst damit nicht
klarkommen und ziemlich ziemlich sauer
deswegen sind und wozu führt dass wenn
man sauer ist dass sie einfach weil sie
schlecht sind beleidigen am laufenden
band vor allen dingen gerne in pvp
kämpfen das sieht dann so aus man spiel
zum beispiel nur ohne treffer das habe
ich in letzter zeit sehr oft gespielt
erkennt der spielmodus bestimmt da hat
man ja wie bei jump liege mache seinen
job nur an mit ihren modulen sich so ein
bisschen verändern und am ende hat meine
den kampf das pvp element pvp traders
chaos absolutes chaos ganz schlimm nur
abstauber aber das ist eine andere sache
denn stellt euch vor ihr kämpft
eins-gegen-eins gegen so einen typen der
vielleicht nicht so gut ist okay und
dann klatsche den weg und was macht er
dann
dann geht es erst richtig los sagt er
nämlich nicht so da weiß ich ins
fäustchen zu hause im keine ahnung
flucht seine wand an zuhause nennen in
der frucht euch ein erwartet richtig
richtig aus und schreibt dann so etwas
wie du
wie gesagt ich möchte jetzt noch betont
hatte dass nichts schlimmes
minecraft schlecht zu sein aber dann
kommst du damit klar ich bin selbst
nicht die beste minecraft spieler und
ich rege mich selbst auf habe mich
jemand kälte besser ist als ich dann
schreie ich vielleicht fuhren sollen bei
mir zu hause aber schreibe ich meine
monitor an und sagte ihm ich in der man
bekommt nichts davon mit aber was diese
leute machen ist wir sind einfach
schlecht sie verpacken und dann fangen
sie an zu beleidigen zwar aufs übelste
und erfreut mich so was gibt dir das
recht dazu der schweizer den kennen wir
bestimmt auch alle sehr sehr gut vorne
geraden spielmodi wie jump league oder
and ride jump gibt die spielmodi hat
generell sehr beliebt sind und in dem
man sich verbessert wenn man viel spielt
herr kommen ein paar leute raus sein
stehen so ein paar leute die auch
vielleicht nicht so super cool sind
lasst mich euch meine geschichte
erzählen wir denken jetzt mal meinen
blick zeiten zurück da hatte ich eine
person die ich sagte ihm nahm jetzt
nicht ich sage auch nicht was ich mit
der person gemacht hat oder welche
welchen kontakt zu der person hatte aber
die person war relativ weit oben in der
jump liquider liste die war glaube ich
irgendwie mal auf platz eins platz zwei
und ich habe nichts persönlich gegen die
person nicht von dieser person kult oder
finde immer noch cool gibt mir viel
geholfen bei vielen videos sehr cooler
zuschauer oder zuschauerin super person
super personen aber die geschichte ist
die folgender leute ich hab dann mit
dieser person ein bisschen geredet und
die hat mir so erzählt was man so machen
muss um quasi ganz oben in dieser top
ten liste zu sein als einer von zwei zu
sein und zwar gibt es wirklich leute die
dann am tag vier stunden jeden tag vier
stunden lämmer energy spielen viel
schönen jumping spielt viel streit
abspielen die leute gibt es wirklich
fragt manchmal warum die da oben sind
und nicht nur das es sind nicht nur
diese vier stunden sondern auch wenn man
dann irgendwie mal modul hat in dem man
nicht weiter kommt wo man irgendwie
immer probleme hat dann gibt es wirklich
leute da draußen die sich in den
singleplayer setzen und diese module
nachbauen um die zu üben
ich darf jetzt nichts dazu wir können
euch eure eigene meinung dazu bilden ob
das cool oder uncool ist aber lassen auf
jeden fall auch die leute die richtig
richtig krass ab schwitzen in den runden
und total übertreiben oder fragt man die
zum beispiel irgendwas sagen was nettes
so nach dem motto hey oder so
wie geht denn ich schreibe zurück denn
steps sind für die das allerwichtigste
ist allerwichtigste ist ganz ganz oben
zu stehen auf dem leaderboard und die
beste kg zu haben und jedes spiel zu
gewinnen und da darf auf jeden fall
nicht in der runde getippt werden ich
kann es verstehen wenn man nicht haben
möchte diesen schweizern möchte ich
einfach sagen leute beruhigt euch
es ist ein spiel ist es nicht so wichtig
tipp nummer drei ist relativ ähnlich wie
typ nummer 2 auch es ist auch ein
schweizer aber ein bisschen anderen form
denn schwizer nummer zwei gibt es zu
dass er bisschen übertreiben mit
minecraft nummer 3 gibt es aber nichts
mit diesem thema wie so oft auch
entscheidung getroffen wo man einfach so
sieht das die leute total ab geben
vollgas geben nach einer millisekunde
schon am ziel sind und findet man hat
gerade den shader eingestellt da sind
die schon im ziel so ungefähr und dann
sagt man einfach man selbst überlässt
sauer bin auch sauer ich werde mich auch
wenn ich mal kurz spiele ganz normal und
dann schreibt man irgendwie sowas wie
schwizer und kommt so zurück entweder
beleidigung aber das ist eine andere
sache
jetzt kommt etwas zurück wie nee stimmt
doch überhaupt nicht ich bin gar kein
schweizer und das ist der kritische
punkt bei dieser person dass die leute
ist einfach nicht zugeben und man denkt
oh okay alles klar die person sagt sie
ist kein schweizer ich glaube dafür aber
ich schaue mal so die stelzen und dann
bar tausend gespielte spiele also noch
mal kann er gerne spaß an den spielmodus
haben und dann richtig viel spielen aber
dann muss man das auch irgendwie so bis
hin zu geben finde ich ein bisschen dazu
stehen ich mal wenn irgendwas macht ist
cool aber steht dazu aber die leute
wollen einfach nichts zu geben dann
werden sie quasi gepasst wenn man ihre
stats sucht dann habe ich einmal
geschrieben soja die radio übertreibst
bisschen scheiße ich bin kein schiff in
kürze / 6000 gespielte spiele ich
schreibe so tausende spiele spiele
puppen deswegen leute über ihn das ziel
dass gar kein persönlicher angriff jeder
kann mit seinem leben machen was er
möchte aber steht halt auch einfach dazu
und seit anderen spielern gegenüber
sofern nicht so zu tun als wäre dir als
ubisoft schiller geboren sondern
zuzugeben dass es einfach daran liegt
dass ihr 1000 spiele auf dem konto hat
und nummer vier leute das ist somit die
person die mich am meisten aufregt weil
man ein teilweise auch recht einfach
eine gute runde gespielt da erkennt dass
ihr manche runden sind besser als andere
und am ende seiner runde steht dann lief
richtig gut ich habe alles equipment und
dann steht man am ende gegen zwei gegner
und siehe da die gehen zu zweit auf
einem spielmodus wo teams verboten sind
und dann verständlicherweise lag man
sich in diesem moment richtig auch
damals eine gute runde hingelegt
die versorgung sei mit dem sie an zu
zweit angreifen und wenn das mehrmals
passiert dann ist es auf jeden fall team
ist kann in manchen situation passieren
dass man einfach so nacheinander eine
person angreift oder sogar zu zwei auf
einmal das ist nicht unbedingt ihm nicht
immer wenn zwei leute auf eine person
gehen ist es sofort team ihn wenn leute
einfach mehrmals zu zweit auf einen
drauf gehen es ist in meinen augen
wirklich teaming dann spricht man leute
darauf an
und dann kommt was diese leute aus macht
sie geben es einfach nicht zu und das
macht dann so richtig sauber man schon
ausgeschieden ist wollen gerne einfach
so richtig ausrasten möchte ja was soll
man zu diesen leuten groß sagen mir
fällt gar nicht mehr dazu ein als sagen
achtet darauf dass ihr nicht teams also
auch nicht so ohne euch mit einer person
abzusprechen oder die zu kennen all to
be born draufzugehen
das ist einfach unfair
und zu guter letzt nummer fünf nummer
fünf ist nummer eins relativ ähnlich
weil auch nummer fünf sehr gerne
beleidigt diese personen ist einfach
mental ein bisschen gestört und denkt es
wäre irgendwie cool andere leute im
internet in minecraft zu beleidigen das
im moment wo ich mir denke so legal komm
mal klar auf dein leben des spiels
minecraft jump mike rodgers und
beleidigt die leute vom laufenden band
ohne grund musste vielleicht irgend
personen die jünger ist als du die
vielleicht nicht 16 ist sondern zwölf
oder elf wissen einfach normal kommt in
ruhe spielen möchte und dann kommt
irgendwie person und beleidigt dich und
du bist weg zwölf jahre alt und kannst
damit nicht umgehen und nimmst es die zu
herzen und das ist das schlimme bei
nummer 55 einfach aus prinzip und
grundlegend immer beleidigt wissen
personen die am anfang irgendwie keine
ahnung die rhone starteten die schreiben
irgendwie heil hitler in die kommentare
oder sowas keine beleidigung ist aber
einfach dumm ist es gibt übrigens
genauso in youtube kommentar
das sehe ich so oft und was tut mir in
der seele weh ich meine wirklich etwas
tut mir in der seele weh zu sehen wie
junge zuschauer irgendwas schreiben und
es ist vielleicht nicht weniger witzig
ist ein schlechter witz oder das finden
ältere fläche ich cool aber leute wenn
ihr 15 16 egal welches alter dann
beleidigt diese leute bitte nicht wie
sind noch deutlich jünger als ihr und
die nehmen sich vielleicht wirklich zu
herzen
ich habe selbst eine kleine schwester
und ich weiß wie zerbrechlich leuten im
alter sind also bitte tut mir den
gefallen und eingefallen beleidigt mich
leute im internet gerade wie ihr seht
also es vielleicht jüngere leute sind so
das war's von dem heutigen video ich bin
am ende bist du ausgerastet habe wissen
über die beleidiger gerettet wenn ihr
irgendwelche von den personen erkannt
haben das gerne und in die kommentare
schreiben oder wenn ihr selbst auch
spielertypen kennt ihr euch total nerven
die er dem video nicht aufgetaucht sind
die auch in die kommentare schreiben und
vielleicht noch mal zweites video bis
zum nächsten mal